- [Narrator] From circuit boards
and electronic components that
end up in some Apple products
to patio furniture and
plenty of other things.
A lot of the goods we use every
day are produced in China.
And those factories have
been getting messages
from the local government
that there's not enough electricity.
And a lot of cities have had blackouts.
- Restrictions came quite unexpected,
we're allowed to work
during restricted hours,
which was mostly at night.
- [Narrator] Right now, China is facing
its biggest power crisis.
And more than a decade,
which is leading to power outages
and temporary factory closures
in one of the world's
largest manufacturing hubs.
- If Chinese factories
continue having problems
getting electricity,
there could be ripple
effects around the world.
And the main problem is coal.
China is the world's biggest consumer
of the dirty fossil fuel
and its dependency on it is
exposing some pain points
in the countries transitioned
to a greener feature
while threatening to delay how
quickly we'll be able to get
our made in China products.
To keep manufacturing hubs running
and the lights on for citizens,
China needs a lot of power.
And last year, about 60% of
it came from burning coal.
But recently this demand has soared.
- China recovered from the economic impact
of the COVID-19 pandemic much
earlier than other economies.
So as a result, it has been producing
and exporting more goods,
which require a lot
more electricity usage.
- [Narrator] It's factories
ramped up to make components
for I-phones and video game gadgets
that consumers in the west
wanted while stuck at home.
But China hasn't been
able to source enough coal
from domestic producers because
there's been safety issues
in coal mines and anti-corruption probes.
Plus, flooding in one of
China's coal mining provinces
is also threatening the supply.
At the same time, importing
hasn't been easy either.
- They have imposed this unofficial ban
on Australian coal imports.
One of the usual sources that
they would go to for coal.
- [Narrator] Since late last year,
China has barred coal from Australia.
After Canberra called for an
independent global inquiry
into the origins of COVID-19.
So China has had to find other suppliers
in Indonesia and Mongolia.
But sourcing has been
getting more difficult
because now other parts of the world
are beginning to emerge
from the pandemic too.
And there's not enough coal to go around.
- So, right now, coal prices have climbed
to their highest level in a decade.
And so when coal prices climb higher,
it really disincentivizes
power plants in China
from generating more power,
even if the demand is there.
- That's because until very recently,
government rules prevented power producers
from passing on higher costs to customers.
So instead of firing up the generators,
they've chosen to cut down production.
All this has led to widespread
power shortages in China.
(speaking in foreign language)
It's also effected factories like this one
in the Southern manufacturing
hub of Guangdong.
- We'd have to adapt ourselves
to these restrictions.
- [Narrator] Thomas Broertjes's manages
this patio furniture factory.
He says since early August,
he's been receiving text messages
from the local government
asking to restrict power usage.
- They send daily message.
They give a specific period
where you are allowed
to work in and yeah,
then we will have to adjust
our production schedule.
- [Narrator] So his factory
had to occasionally close
during peak hours and open
between 11:00 PM and 8:00 AM,
according to the
government's instructions.
- We didn't have restrictions
like that you cannot totally work anymore.
So that we were still be able
to continue our production.
- But several other companies
haven't been so lucky,
including several Apple suppliers,
Concraft, an electronic
component supplier,
said it had to temporarily
suspend production
for about five days.
Eson precision which
supplies mechanical parts,
and Unimicron technology which
makes printed circuit boards,
also stopped production
for about five days.
Apple didn't respond to
a request for comment.
Meanwhile, more than 10
chip related companies
in China's Eastern city of Cochin,
said they temporarily
closed their facilities
for about five days at
the end of September.
Broertjes says he
continues to get messages
from the government
about whether the factory
can use power normally.
For now, production is back on schedule,
but he says he's prepared to
shut down at a moment's notice.
- The chance is always there.
I have learned that in China,
you have to cooperate with
a certain flexibility.
The rules are set, it is what it is.
That's what we have to do.
- [Narrator] And the
Cooperation will be important
because Beijing has set
itself a big climate goal.
(speaking in foreign language)
- [Narrator] To make that
happen, China has been using
a target, electricity use must grow
at a lower rate than GDP,
but in the first half of this year,
electricity use rose more than GDP
and hitting Beijing's target
could become more difficult
as winter approaches and
demands for heating increase.
- These power outages really
show how reliant China
is still on coal, despite
their push to transition
into greener energy sources
and curb carbon emissions.
And so going into the future,
they're going to be forced
to balance some goals.
- [Narrator] To balance
these goals, Beijing hinted
in mid-October that it would
need to rethink its path
and pacing for reaching
its climate target.
China's leadership has
said electricity curves
for high energy users,
such as steel and cement
will continue to stay.
But to address immediate needs,
the country has now stepped
up its coal supplies
while allowing prices of
coal fired power to increase.
With all the unpredictability,
factory owners like Broertjes are starting
to think about how to ensure
their own stable power source.
- We are also considering
about the sustainable energy,
can we plant solar panels on our roof?
Is there are no alternative
way of getting energy,
and besides a diesel generator?
- [Narrator] But, if in the
short run, the power crisis
in China continues.
The impact could hit closer to home.
- That could weigh on
manufacturing activity
and economic growth in China,
which subsequently could
affect the rest of the world.
Whether people are going to
be able to get their products
on time or we'll even face
higher costs for them.